hello guys my name is a Chennai welcome
back to my say plus plus series today
we're going to be talking all about a
keyword called mutable and how we can
use it so mutable actually has two
fairly different uses one of them is to
do with Const if you don't know how
constants work in C++ you can check out
the video that I made yesterday about
that just click on the card or the link
in the description below and the other
use is actually with lambdas so we'll
kind of cover both of them I know I
haven't actually talked about lambdas
and what they even are a few of you're
probably wondering what I'm talking
about but definitely will in the future
but I thought just make a quick video to
cover what mutable actually means
because the two cases are actually
rather different the word the English
word mutable of course means that it's
something that is liable to change it's
something that can change and you've
probably heard me say immutable before
meaning that something cannot be changed
mutable as the opposite of that means
something can change so when we talk
about mutable in the context of Const
obviously we're talking about something
that is kind of Const but actually can
change so it's almost like mutable
reverses the meaning of Const we really
only have one application of mutable in
that context and that is with class
methods so let's take a look at that I'm
going to create a class here called
entity I'm going to give it one private
member which is going to be in name I'm
also going to write a getter for this
function so we'll have a Const STD
string reference we'll call it get name
it will good function will be marked as
Const if you don't know what that means
and check out the video that I made
yesterday about constants a plus plus
and this will just basically return our
name okay so we have a fairly basic
function here together I'm actually
going to move this down over here the
Const over here means that were not
allowed to modify the actual class
members so I can't
for example reassign name to be
something else and really this applies
to every variable the primary reason for
making these methods Const in the first
place and kind of promising that you're
not going to touch the class is because
if we actually do wind up having some
kind of Const entity object over here we
would be able to call those cost methods
whereas if they weren't marked as Const
we actually wouldn't be able to do that
so that's why we mark these methods as
Const
the first place however in some
situations we kind of do still want to
market Methodist Const because for all
intents and purposes it is constant it's
not modifying the object they say but
maybe just maybe it needs to just touch
that variable over there that's kind of
in the entity class technically but not
really meant to kind of be there I'll
give you an example let's just say that
for debugging purposes we wanted to
count how many times this function was
called in our program we might have some
kind of integer pulled debug count or
something which is initialized to zero
and every time we call this function we
just wanted to increment that count now
we can't do that here so a solution
would be to kind of get rid of Const and
then we would be fine right but now we
can't call it over here and we've kind
of broken this and really this is just a
getter for name so surely we can kind of
just increment this without losing the
constants of this method and of course
we could move this out into some other
class or something and that will be
totally fine but that's going to be
messy because this applies specifically
to this functional through this class so
what we can do is restore our quantity R
and just mark this variable debug count
as mutable I mean we're allowing
constant methods to change it and now
all was well in the world we can do this
Constanta seed stuff here and we can
also have a nice constant method which
actually does modify this particular
class member so marking a class member
is mutable means that constants inside
that class can actually modify that
member that right there is probably the
most common usage of mutable by quite a
quite a big margin using mutable with
class members like this is probably the
only time you'll ever use it to be
honest but there is however one more use
for mutable and I might as well cover
that today it's to do with lambdas so
without making this too complicated
because I haven't covered lambdas the I
suppose that we had some kind of
bearable here we'll make in X equal
Sarah and then I wanted to declare some
kind of
so I'll just call it ass and I'll write
some code over here maybe do something
like Prince how low to the console I
don't know it could be really anything
that's just a lambda a lambda is
basically like a little throwaway
function that you can write and assign
to a variable quickly like we've done
here we can call a lambda just like any
other function by using its name like
this and just specifying any parameters
we might have now suppose that we
actually wanted to use x over here like
instead of printing color I want it to
print
X that's going to be fine I can just
pass in X like this however I do need to
define some kind of capture method so we
can either send this variable by
reference like this or by value like
that or you can just type in equals or
absent to send everything basically
that's using here by reference or by
value now suppose that this lambda
actually did some extra stuff maybe did
X plus plus however we still wanted this
to be by value you'll see that if I
actually change this to be by a value
and I try to do something like X plus
plus I get an error and what I actually
would have to do in this situation is
maybe make another variable assign it to
this and then kind of essentially
incremental or modify that variable I
have to copy it and I have to basically
create a local variable which can
actually take the value from the
variable and passing in this is a little
bit messy so what I could do instead is
use that wonderful mutable keyword so
I'll go back to doing this and all I
have to do is say that this lambda is
mutable by just sticking that mutable
keyword right there what this means is
that variables that you passed by a
value like I just did with this X you
can change them and of course what this
will do is basically what I showed you
with that y example it's going to create
a local variable item it's just that in
your source code it's going to look a
lot cleaner and of course outside of
this function so like after I call this
lambda over here X will still be set to
eight it will not increment and be set
to nine you are not passing it by
reference now like you would if you did
this you're still passing it by value so
it still will be eight here because
you're just copying that value eight
into this lambda alright that is what
the mutable keyword is again as I said
earlier you'll be using it with classes
and Const like 90% of the time I
honestly do not think I've ever written
it inside a land like the
before it just it just doesn't happen in
practice I haven't even seen code like
this very often at all if you have any
more questions about mutable or
constants or anything you can leave a
question in the comment section below
I'll try to respond to as many as I can
if you guys enjoy this video you can
show me the e did by hitting that like
button below and you can also support
the series on patreon to make sure that
more episodes are made by going to the
patreon account for sex Cherno and get
some cool rewards like seeing excess
early and contributing to the planning
and suggesting topics and all that fun
stuff I'll see you guys in next video
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]